Hey traders, it's Mike here and in this
video I'm going to talk about the
liquidity finder
indicator tool that we created for Ninja
Trader 8. I'm going to explain what it
does and how to fine-tune it for any
market. You know, the problem that most
traders have with their tools is they
don't know how to use them and you know,
especially if there's a lot of settings.
The problem that I see a lot of traders
have that use tools to identify things
like
order blocks or supply and demand, you
know, fair value gaps, etc. All all
these different ways to define levels in
the market is, you know, what an
indicator does, you know, you program it
and it just looks specifically for that
pattern, right? You open up any supply
and demand indicator and you get the
same thing, right? You get zones
everywhere, you know, boxes everywhere.
You get zones and boxes stacked on top
of each other. Um cuz what the tools do
is they just detect a pattern and they
draw
a rectangle or box or zone
based off of what it is trained to
identify. That's it. That's all they do.
They don't have any clue or any idea
whether the level like what is appearing
right now in the market
is like one that held recently or or if
it's more like one that failed recently,
whether price respected the level or
blew through that level, right? So as a
trader, you often have to, you know, use
your intuition and and make a guess, you
know, is is this right or wrong? And to
me that's always been a problem with
zones and that's why we created the
liquidity finder, you know, which is a
tool that actually will score zones in a
sense of, you know, whether it's based
off of similar zones that happened
recently, whether those zones are
holding or not. Okay, so what the
liquidity finder does is it scores every
zone and then hides the ones that don't
reach your threshold. You could set your
threshold as high as, you know,
100%, you know, one that's sort of
worked every single time. I don't think
you need to go that high. You can go as
as as 75% I think is good. The default
is set to 50 and you know, you can go
lower than 50 meaning you know, you can
go as low as one. You obviously can't do
zero, but you know,
sometimes I I check markets with a
setting of five because again, you know,
there's other parts other settings that
you can adjust as well. Maybe you want
to have see
you know, other zones that appeared and
you know, the lower zone score that you
go like say you go down to say five,
obviously it's going to show you
zones that failed and and didn't fail
based off of or I'll say zones that
failed and didn't fail, but it's going
to rank these zones off of previous
zones that also probably failed. But
again, you know, when you're start
adjusting some of the the rankings, some
of the settings, you'll understand why.
So, what liquidity finder does is it
detects so the first step is it detects,
right? It scans for three liquidity
patterns, you know, based on volume and
price action. Second is it's going to
score it and this is the important part,
right? Because you know, the detection
is where most indicators stop.
Period. They detect
a certain pattern and that's it. They
draw the zone on there. But what
liquidity finder does, which
no other indicators really do on the
market is it builds sort of its own
little database that it's ranking it
against. You know, it
checks the higher time frame context,
checks the volume, checks and finds the
most similar past bars and ask did this
price actually follow through?
Okay, meaning did this zone actually
hold or not? And then three, the third
step is you know, once it has it's sort
of its score, you know,
then it's going to filter the ones that
meet the minimum score, it's going to
it's going to print on your chart. If it
doesn't meet the minimum score, then
it's not. And you know, there's other
factors,
um
you know, cool down effect which I'll
talk about, you know, overlaps. You they
one of these other filters, then it's
not going to print. So, you're actually
filtering out the zones
that in most I'll say historically, but
in most recent history, because that's
really what matters in the market is
what's happening right now in the
market. Is are these zones holding or
not?
Now, what they do is they color the
different types of zones on your chart.
So, if it's sort of this
actually lime and red for bullish and
bearish. I just have the lime color up
here, but that means it's between 70 to
100%.
That's high confidence, right? And that
means that, you know, most similar
patterns followed through. Doesn't mean,
you know, just cuz you have one that's
you know, 100%
in the past doesn't mean it's going to
automatically work, right? Because I
mean, you know, past performance is not
indicative of future results, but
generally speaking, you know, if a level
if a certain type of level held in most
recent history, then chances are it is
going to hold again until it doesn't
hold. I mean, that's that's how the
markets work. We we understand that, you
know,
orange is sort of that middle range
between 34 to 69%. So, you're medium
confidence ones. Um
yeah, you're going to pair it with your
own confluence of other tools or even,
you know, order flow if you want. Light
gray would be the lower confidence ones.
It's only visible if you lower the
threshold. Okay? So, you know, what
you're going to see is you're going to
see up triangles and down triangles. Up
for bullish
uh levels
down for bearish levels and have these
things what we call go zone lines,
right? Which is the exact trigger level
where you're going to be wanting to get
long or short from.
No repainting, so it's on the bar close
confirmed, you know, once the the bar
closes.
And so, what you're going to be seeing
on your chart are the high confidence
signals.
Okay? So,
you know, this is a chart that I sent
out before and you can see on here,
okay, before we get into actual charts,
you know, you can these little green
lines
these little red lines, okay, there's
one here.
These are the go no go zones. So, if you
trade above it,
you know, that that's the area you'd
want to get long. I prefer to close
above it actually to get long or get
short.
You know, I I I just find those to be
the the higher percentage trades on top
of even the scoring. So, green is is
launch zones where markets price
rocketed off the bottom. You can see
here base off this chart and look MNQ on
the 30-second chart. This is just the
default settings, right? You see the
green areas in here where price
started going up. Okay, we're seeing
some other levels come in here, some
shorts, some longs, and you know, this
red zone here. Right now, this was
interesting because you had a resistance
zone
which turned into
what?
A demand zone. Right? Supply demand.
What was previously resistance becomes
support, right? You see how the market
came up, traded back down, and then went
back up. Okay, now all these boxes that
you see on here, all these zones
are scored zones, okay? The ones that
don't meet the requirements are not
being shown on here. Now, just really
quick again, you know, the the the color
codes
lime is actually I should have a red
one, you know, on this graphic here. Um
lime color, which is green and red,
would be 70 to 100. Orange whether it's
bullish or bearish
is 34 to 69%.
And light gray is below 33%. So, these
sort of these light orange colors are
in that zone between 34 to 69. The green
and the red are the stronger signals.
That's why we have them as green and red
cuz that's where a lot of traders are
going to be focused on is is the green
and reds. When you start getting into
these orange ones and even grays later,
um you're going to be, obviously, more
focused on what the
order flow or price action is showing
you if you look at order flow.
Um, but that's why we have the uh, green
up triangles and the red down triangles
to, you know, sort of keep you
uh, alert as to if it's bullish or
bearish. I decided not to color them
different colors simply because they are
the weaker signals and I know not
everyone is going to use them.
And again, you know, similar to what we
saw here where previous resistance
becomes support, you know, this is the
one-minute chart. Right? This is your
previous resistance. Now it's become
support, right? We drew this red
resistance zone here, right? And where
this triangle appears is where this zone
starts drawing out. You see how the
market comes back up? It's acting as
resistance, comes off, trades back up
there, acts as resistance. Even in here
when we came back up later, it spends
the next, you know, 5-7 minutes trading
in that resistance. Now it starts
shooting out. Now that resistance area
has become your support. We drew a new
zone out there.
Okay?
So, again, you know, these zones are
scored
based off of
their rankings, you know? So, if it's
red, it's over 75%. If it's this orange,
you know, it's a it's between 34% to
69%.
Okay? So, there are three layers in
Liquidity Finder before it prints a
zone, okay? And again, you know, I have
layer 1 2 3.
Okay? Now,
just because it's 1 2 3,
it's layer one, layer two, layer three.
It could be in any order how you adjust
these. So, layer one, you know, you go
you deal with volatility first.
I I tend to deal with that, but once I
find a level, you know, sort of
volatility, I tend to stay with it. I
don't vary
much
really where I I vary a lot is,
obviously, Nasdaq's going to trade
different than bonds.
Okay? So, volatility is different.
Um,
but I I just tend to, you know, once I
sort of
once I hone in on my volatility for one
market, it stays there.
Uh so, we'll talk about the settings in
a second, but, you know, volatility it
scales
nearly every threshold, right? Then,
next would be sort of the volume
baseline to match the instrument's
volume rhythm. The second layer that you
can adjust are sort of the frequency
dials, right? The minimum score, the
cool down. You know, the minimum score
is like, you know, what I was talking
about with the colors with the zones.
Um
you know, 75 and above would be red and
green.
34 to 69 would be that orange, and, you
know, 1 to 33 would be the gray. The
cool down period, pattern match depth,
to choose between a sniper chart or an
active scalp chart, meaning, you know,
do you want a lot more signals or less
signals? Um then, you want to teach the
engine, right, what is successful,
right? And by that, you're going to go
to the learning bars and follow through
thresholds to define what a winning move
means to you, okay? And the scoring
brain, you know, the back end of the
indicator will help you uh calibrate
everything.
So, for example, right, the
volatility default is three, right? And
in that scale zone height caps, you
know, order block displacement, follow
through, et cetera. Um keep it short,
three to five on fast spiky markets like
NQ or gold. Lengthen it for slower
markets,
um you know, bonds, et cetera. But,
again, you know, you can adjust it
because nowadays, you know, like me, I I
use time-based charts. If you're on a
slower moving chart, maybe a range-based
chart, you you may
adjust it accordingly. Volume baseline
is sort of, you know, what these things
like volume surges are measured against,
right? The fractal strength. It's
measured against the volume baseline.
So, you match it to your volume's
instrument instrument's volume cycle.
Shorter for markets with uh sharp
session-driven volume like gold around
the London even New York overlap, right?
So I mean this is just an example,
right? Again, the default is set to
20.
Okay.
Now, sniper mode active scalper,
you know, active scalper is more like
day trader.
Again, you know, I I I write minimum
liquidity score 65 to 70 five.
Even though in between is sort of the
middle, 70 would be 70 and above is the
green and
red.
69 below is is the orange ones.
Which
I tend to keep both on, you know,
because I want to see the the lower
scores as well. Um zone cool down 10 to
20 bars displacement strength you know,
1.5 is fine. Volume surge two. Now these
are a little bit different than the
default settings, but again, you know,
you got to find what you're comfortable
with. And again, you know, it's
difficult when you release an indicator
because I have to set a defaults for
everybody, okay? And I want you guys to
realize, you know, these defaults are
set for equity markets. If you're in um
bonds or currencies, you're going to
need to adjust it, okay? So now if
you're an active scalper, um
as opposed to, you know,
I I I I should have changed it from act
active scalper to more day trader
intraday trader. Minimum liquidity score
35 to 40. Zone cool down two to three
bars reaction sensitivity
uh two pattern match depth one to two.
Again, you know, these
these are just suggestions, right? It's
not like Mike says it has to be this.
You find the one that is suitable to
your trading style, okay?
Define what a winning move means for
you, right? Scoring asks are the bars
This is the important part, the scoring
part, right? It asks
the bars similar to this one that's
currently has a zone being drawn, how
many follow through, okay?
Now, there's a couple settings that
you're going to want to adjust with
those. The learning bars, the follow
through threshold. Learning bars, how
many bars forward the engine waits
before judging a past pattern, okay?
Shorten it to length
shorten it to learn quick scalp
reactions, lengthen it to learn setups
behind the bigger slower swing moves,
okay? So, if you're going to shorten the
learning bars, obviously it's going to
pick things up quicker. You're going to
make it longer, bigger, more than 10,
it's going to
have bigger swing moves. Um follow
through threshold, how far price must
travel inside that window to count as a
win, meaning you know, the higher you go
the the 2.0 default is one.
Um
and again, you know, follow through
could go in decimals, so you can even
have 1.1, 1.2, but I generally, I I
don't like to shave things down that
finite, you know, where it's oh, it's
got to be 1.3 in this market and 1.2 in
the other market. I go 1, 1.5, too.
Um
so, you raise it to two and and the
engine only learns from larger moves,
okay? So, a high score literally means
these led to big moves recently,
okay?
And you know, the important part is
you're not just adjusting the cosmetics,
you know, you're defining how the
engine's scoring brain works around your
edge.
Okay, so let's just jump into some
defaults examples. So, these are the
setting defaults, okay? So, see
liquidity engine, pattern match depth is
three, memory length is uh 25. For now,
we'll just uh we won't use the chart
context.
Um liquidity hunting, volume surge is
set to two, displacement one, fractal
strength one.
Liquidity score 50 is the default. Then
again, you know, if you if you just want
to see the red and
lime green zones, you'd set it to uh
70.
Zone cool down five is the default.
Volatility is three.
You could go higher, you know, I would
go like three five 10 15.
Um you don't need to go like three four
five six seven. I you know, I like make
sensible jumps. Volume baseline is 20.
The liquidity check three reaction
sensitivity level is three. Learning
bars
set to 10.
It's a default follow through threshold
set to one.
And active zones to show is set to six.
I mean you could set it higher.
Sometimes you know,
if you're on a very fast moving market,
the reason it's active zones showing to
six is because, you know, if you set it
to a higher level like 50 or 25, you
know, you want to look back on your
chart. That's fine. You could do that,
but just remember,
you know, it's just going to put a
little bit more
not stress, but you know, it's it's
going to do it's going to draw up more
zones basically cuz it's going back um
it's drawing the 50
inactive zones out there. So, you know,
sometimes people don't want to see it.
Okay, that that's all. I keep it at six,
but if you want to see every single
zone, you know, you'd set it higher, you
know, 25 or 50. Okay, so again, you
know, this is what the default settings
look like. Okay? So, I'm going to I put
this chart on here because I'm going to
show you. So,
the green the green and the red is set
to, you know, is the zones above 75. The
orange ones are, you know, between 34
and 69.
Okay, so here, right? Now, minimum
liquidity score default is 50, max is
100. 75 is good enough.
One is the lowest, but five is fine. If
if you want to go low, you don't have to
go as low as one.
You have to be honest, you know, when
when I look at one and and five,
the differences are are quite small.
It's negligible.
So, here's with liquidity zone score set
to five, right? So, you can see
still got the red and the green,
but now you got this gray one in here.
Okay. Now, people sometimes ask, you
know, like here, right? This is the
default settings, right? I got a green
one here.
Whereas earlier
when I set it to five, I don't have it
here because on some of these settings
you know, like the zone cool down,
um
is
it's
you got to remember, now as I've set the
liquidity score to five as opposed to 50
when I set it to 50, I have the zone,
but now I've gone to a lower zone.
There's this other zone in between. So,
there's the cool down, right? The the
time spent between bars is different.
That's why this other zone isn't
appearing here.
Right? That we have on the default
settings. So, I've got a higher zone
coming in here around, you know,
this is 3680.
But I got another zone up here around
3720.
Okay? So, that's that's the difference
cuz, you know, when when you start
making some changes, even if it's just
something as simple as one little change
it has a ripple effect on how it's going
to start scoring everything else. Okay?
Now, learning bars, right? More learning
equals fewer signals. Okay? So, the or
the default here is set to
10.
So, if I set it to 25
Okay? This is it's set at 25.
This is the default setting. So, when I
set it to a higher score
now those orange color zones are out,
right? And and now I've got stronger
green zones. Like I have more green
zones appearing because the learning
has more bars to
understand what's going on in the
market.
As opposed to with the default settings,
right? It's it's acting a little bit
faster, so it's showing some weaker
zones even though, you know, it looks
like some of these zones are coming in
right around the same level, right? This
one with the default setting is orange
and you know, these are
orange as well.
But now it's a green one because it's
done more learning.
Okay, now volatility. Yeah, this is when
you set the 15. Default is three. Three
is what I recommend most traders start
at. The higher you go, the smoother it
attempts
the smoother it
makes the volatility curve, okay? So,
this is where the volatility is set to
as opposed to when the default is set to
three. So again, you know, you see these
orange zones.
And here it comes in stronger
green zones. I mean, you do have this
red one that failed.
Right? And on the default, you don't
have this red short over here.
Okay, so there's a short here and a
short here
that didn't appear with the default
settings.
Now the learning bars
set to 25. Again, you know, just really
quick with the learning bars,
um
change to 25 to have a more time in
training. And this is important for
periods of choppiness, okay?
When
the market looks choppy or you know,
you're coming into a time of, you know,
markets are interesting because there
are certain times of the day that
markets can be choppy. Okay, lunch time
for example is a good example. Um
and if you are going to change the
learning bars to a higher number, you
could also change the the threshold a
little bit higher, the follow through
threshold. Okay, so this is learning
set to 10, right? The default setting.
And you can see it looks a bit choppy
here, you know, you got these buys
up in here,
you know, buy buy buy, you know, and and
it's hard sometimes in choppy markets to
trade. And I mean, one of the reasons
why it's choppy is because look at the
time. It's 9:30 until, you know, 7:00 in
the morning.
Right? This is Euro currency. Okay? And
then, you know, it did catch some nice
moves up, some moves down, some moves
back up. But, you know what? It's it's
still kind of choppy. Why is because
it's the time of day. It's the middle of
the night.
Versus when you set the learning to 25,
it looks a lot cleaner, right? This This
is 25. This is 10. Right? You got
shorts, longs.
Long, short, long, short, short.
Whereas here, you know, it's just a bit
more cleaner
on the way up and the way down. All
right? And you're seeing stronger zones,
right? I didn't adjust the
the scoring percentage, right? It's
still the same, right? It's still at 50.
Minimum liquidity score is still at 50.
Right? But, you see a lot of
these orange orange orange orange orange
orange, right? But, when I go here, you
know, I
It's red. It's It's It's It's It's
stronger because it's had more time to
to read them. Okay?
Volatility set to 15, learning bars set
to 10. So, now I've I've ramped up the
volatility Let's say ramped up the
volatility. I just made it higher.
Um learning bars still set to 10. 15 and
10 here.
And again, you know, the start looks
similar to the one that was earlier
chart. So, I got the red here. I got the
red here.
And I've got a red signal here. Okay?
When I
make the learning bars
set, you know, volatility set to 15,
learning bars set to 10. Volatility is
the one that's changed. Um
Yeah, it it just affects the
the volatility curve that it's scoring
against.
This is versus the default, right? I
don't have the shorts in here or or here
or in here.
Now, the memory length default is set to
25,
but when you set it to 200, right now
it's going back
more
to score things. So, this is
when it's set at 200. Okay, so I've got
you know, the this long here, a short
here, long and a long.
So, I've got
three longs and one short.
Okay, we include this one. So, one two
three four longs, one short versus the
defaults.
You know, I had a long here,
but on the defaults it's a short. I
still got that long. I've got another
long here, another long, long, long,
long,
long. So, it's you can just see the the
difference is that's coming in, right? I
had a short here
and a long here.
But,
that's when it's set to 200.
Here it's set to just the default of 25.
And it's just again, you know,
depends how far back you want to go. The
defaults are the great are are something
that you can set for most markets and
it's your starting point. Now, the
fractal strength set to one or
default is one, but if you set it to
0.1, all right, that says low as you can
go. So, it's going to be
a little bit less
stronger.
Now,
when I say less stronger, that doesn't
mean you're going to get a lot more
signals because again, you know,
remember, there's things like the
there's you know, when when you look at
the settings, there's all these settings
that this one also feeds into liquidity
score,
cool down,
the learning bars, etc. So, you know,
you start changing one or two of these
and you're going to see some different
signals. So, again, you know, fractal
strength set to 0.1.
Okay, so now I've got this short here,
okay, which is a nice little trade here.
Down, comes back up.
Whereas the defaults, right? I don't
have that short here.
Okay? Go back.
Right?
There's a long then followed by a short.
Here I don't have that long followed by
the short.
Right? This was the default. So, you're
seeing a little bit more signals come in
quicker here
that you don't have with the default
settings.
So again, you know, the default settings
are are there for a reason. That's
That's your starting point for most
markets. You don't need to
massively change every single setting.
I mean, if if you want to and you want
to test out different combinations,
you're you're more than welcome to, but
you know, for most markets the default
is good enough. So, your tuning
workflow, you know, start on the
defaults, right? Set you know, layer two
might be the the volatility and volume
baselines.
Um
you know, layer two, or sorry, step
three, which is layer two, you know,
figure out how how many zones you really
want to be seeing on your your charts.
Um and you know,
let it warm up. Give it Make sure you
got enough data that's being loaded onto
your chart
to recalibrate, you know, for the
testing.
Okay?
Um
again, you know, the the
default for that setting, let's go back
here.
Right? Memory length is is 25, which is
good for most people. But again, you
know, if if you want to go higher to
200, even though I say say right here,
give the engine 200 bars,
if you want to.
All right? I have it set at 25. I find
for my type of trading 25 is good
enough.
Here's a tip. The single highest im-
impact change for most traders is the
minimum liquidity score. Raise it
for a quieter, stronger chart. Okay?
Um
So, just uh
here, just really quick here. Well,
let's just
Um here, we'll just add a fresh one on
it to our chart here.
Okay, so these are the default settings.
Okay.
So,
you know, if you if you say, for
example, you set that to 200,
all right? The memory length 200.
I should I should make this a little
smaller.
I'll show it here.
Okay.
So, that's 200, right? Versus 25. Um you
know, if you just want to see the strong
zones, you can set it to 75.
70, you know, 70 if you wanted to.
So, I've taken out some of these other
zones, you know? So, you're seeing what
how it's scoring, you know, the
strongest zones, right? And you can see
Um let me get something up here real
quick.
Right? You're seeing the strong zone
here, these very strong zones here.
Yeah, those
nice zone here, then this one flipped
also.
Right? It doesn't look like much, but
this you're talking to move from 820
up to 900, over 900. Okay?
Um
let's go back here, take a Let's look at
some of these settings.
Uh
you know, learning bars, you know,
jump it up to 25 if you wanted to.
Again, I've got the memory length here,
so you're seeing a slightly more signals
coming in there cuz it's the amount of
data that it's looking at is going to be
different. Um you know, even if you
wanted to you know
volume search threshold, you know,
okay, and you can go down to 1.5.
Go to one, go to two or three, 2.5.
You know, if that's
This is uh volume search right. I
lowered it down from two to 1.5. So,
you're seeing a little bit more shorts
here.
Okay, some more shorts in here.
Um
you know, if say you raise it up to
three.
Okay.
Still kind of similar.
Um you know, fractal strength, you go
down to 0.1 or I don't know, just choose
a number, three, 0.3.
Okay, so you see less here or shorts
coming in there.
Um yeah, I'm just
messing around here.
Yeah, let's make that 15.
Now, I'm changing the volatility.
Okay, so again, you know, it's
everything changes when you
not everything changes, but there's
there's minor changes, right? So, you
know, make the zone cool down to 15.
Okay, well, there's enough space in
between those. Again, cuz I got it set
up at 75. If I had gone down lower, 50,
you know, when you go up to 75, some of
these settings
still appear. So, you can see like these
these zones, right? I've got it set at
50.
You know, these orange zones
are the less stronger ones, but they're
still some of them are are still quite
strong, obviously.
Um you know, there's a but zone cool
down back down to 50.
Um
liquidity strength or liquidity
sorry, reaction level.
Oh, just really quick here. So
So a good example. So you can see
here, right? There's a green
a green
a green, but there's no zones being
drawn out, okay?
Right? So there's no zones. That is
because
that one little setting that I referred
to earlier.
Um how many zones you want to be showing
on your chart?
Active zones to show is set to six. If I
make it higher, you know, 25
Okay, so yeah, now those zones are being
drawn out. Okay? It's just you know,
sometimes you know, people just don't
want to have so many things drawn on
their chart, right? They just want to be
looking at the most recent stuff that's
that's taking place. Um
you know, follow through threshold you
know, if I make it say three
Okay, so you can see you know, less
signals coming in.
Um go back to one on that.
And yeah, even if you lower the
liquidity score down to say five
means you know, it obviously has to have
a score
to be showing up on your chart.
Um you know,
that's what you're looking at.
Then again, you know, say you wanted to
set that to five and you know, the
liquid follow through threshold you
could also adjust
back up to two from one.
Again, you're starting to see you know,
these gray zones are the ones that are
are the zones that have the liquidity
score between um one and
33.
That's what the grey zones are. But we
have the triangles that tell you if it's
a bullish one or a bearish one, right?
Obviously the red is bearish, green is
bullish.
So just remember, right? You know, a
level isn't real because it's pretty on
your chart, right? It should It should
be real because it's earned, right?
Liquidity finder scores every supply
demand zone against recent history,
hides the noise, hides the ones that
aren't that important.
And it doesn't repaint, right? Out of
the box is fine for most markets, but
you can tune it to any market that you
trade. It's built for NinjaTrader 8. So
thanks everyone.
And again, you know, if you haven't got
it yet, now is a great time to get it.
So thanks and I'll see you guys on the
inside. Take care.